Welcome everybody. My name is Peter O'Dwyer
from the University of Pennsylvania and Eakock-Akron Cancer
Research Group. On behalf of myself and Dr.
Rebecca Hubbard and Dr. Neil Maropol,
I'm delighted to welcome you to this session on
real world data. To my knowledge, I think this is the
first real world data
methods workshop that has been held at an AACR
meeting, and we were talking before.
We're gratified to see so many attendees
at the meeting and more virtually.
The
session consists of
three talks with a period for discussion.
What we've decided to do is to give the three talks,
following which there will be about a half an hour for
a panel discussion. And that's so that many of
the questions that come along in sessions like this can be
addressed in different ways by more than one
speaker. So we would like to have that dialogue established.
A couple of housekeeping issues.
There is an audience virtually, and so that
they can hear
when you
want to ask a question, you can come to the microphone, but speak into the
microphone so that the audience can hear.
So I think without any
further ado,
I want to welcome
Dr. Rebecca Hubbard to the microphone.
Dr. Hubbard is the Carl Kawaja and
Wendy Holcomb Professor of Public Health and
Professor of Biostatistics and Data Science at Brown
University. Welcome.
Thank you.
Thank you all for coming out this afternoon to talk with us a bit about methods for
incorporating real world data into clinical trial design.
So I'm a biostatistician, and what I'm going to emphasize in my talk
is both design and analysis issues in incorporating
real world data into clinical trials, but particularly thinking about the
unique aspects of real world data and how that might inform the
way that we think about combining them with trial data in a way that
allows us to learn more and address the deficiencies of trials
without degrading the quality of the evidence that we're generating.
We are currently in an era of enormous enthusiasm
for incorporating real world data into research broadly,
and I think that's been particularly spurred by the
uptick in use of AI and AI allowing us to
access data and unleash data from electronic health records, for
instance, that's in narrative text form that we haven't previously been able to
access. So this is an example of three articles from
recent lay press publications. These came out spanning
the period from October,
no, August of 2025, up through December of 2025, and I
found those within a few seconds of just Google searching for real world data and
health. So there's a ton of enthusiasm about conducting this
kind of research and a lot of hype and promise
and potential for doing this work.
But I think we need to ground all of our analyses and all of our thinking
about the work in a realization that the data are messy,
they are challenging, and it's going to take a lot of methodological
innovation and careful attention to analytic details if we're going to
realize the kind of potential and the kind of promise
that these sort of headlines are touting.
Why is there such enthusiasm for potentially doing this, for
incorporating real world data into randomized control trial design?
We know that clinical trials, randomized trials, are considered the gold
standard for generating estimates of treatment efficacy.
So we already have a design approach that people
feel confident in and that we know reduces risks of certain types of
bias.
But we also know that clinical trials have numerous deficiencies,
most notably that they are extremely expensive, they're
slow, many trials fail to meet their enrollment targets, and there
are just many, many comparisons of different treatment combinations,
different treatment regimens and patterns that we might be interested in, and it's
simply infeasible to conduct a randomized control trial for every single one of
them. So bringing into our research
portfolio real world data, which are collected in the
course of routine practice, and when I say real world data, I'm
generally rolling up all sources collected outside of the
context of a randomized trial. So that would incorporate electronic health
records, administrative claims data, disease registries,
and potentially even more diffuse
data types like social media data or wearable devices.
So all of these secondary data sources potentially give us
access to a lot of opportunities and a lot of benefits,
including lower cost than large randomized trials, larger
sample sizes, and rapid data availability and
access.
But I think one of the most exciting opportunities of doing
research with real world data is the opportunity to access representative
patient populations receiving care in the real world.
So we're able to get a window into health and healthcare and treatment
effectiveness in the context of routine clinical practice, rather
than in the more verified and artificial environment of a randomized
control trial.You can imagine that all of
those benefits seem very appealing and are
spurring the current enormous research interest in using
these data sources for research purposes.
But there's an important caveat, which is that real-world data
differ in fundamental respects compared to randomized control trial
data. So if we're going to incorporate these data into our analyses, we need to
think carefully about the methods that we're going to use.
I tend to think of trials and real-world data as having complementary
strengths and weaknesses, and therefore, we would like to use them in ways that
are complementary. So on this slide, on the left, I have trials, on the
right, I have real-world data. And in the bold red, I've
indicated the strengths of each, and in black, I'm indicating the
weaknesses. And I've tried to line them up so that you can see that they somewhat
complement each other. Trials give us access to high-quality
data, very precise data collection standards, but are slow and
expensive and not necessarily generalizable.
Conversely, real-world data give us access to a broad representative
patient population. They can be assembled relatively quickly and
relatively cheaply, and the word "relatively" is doing a lot of work in that
sentence, because these are difficult to curate,
although not at the level of conducting a randomized control trial.
But data quality is inconsistent.
Data collection standards are unspecified, so we just see
patients according to their own interaction with the healthcare system, which is
not necessarily consistent across patients, providers, or
systems.
So what we'd like to do is use these two sources in a way that benefits from the
strengths of each without degrading the quality of evidence
associated with either. This is an example of two studies that were
conducted answering similar questions, one in a real-world
data population, which is the result on the left, and one in a phase three
clinical trial, which is the result on the right.
So the study that I'm showing here on the left
was an observational study using oncology EHR data from Flatiron
Health to do a head-to-head comparison of two treatments for advanced bladder
cancer.
We conducted that study because, at the time, there was no
head-to-head comparison of these two treatments.
Immunotherapy for advanced bladder cancer had been approved on the basis of a
single-arm trial.
So we were able to obtain the results on the left while the phase
three trial, asking the same question in a similar patient population,
was being conducted. And about six months later, the result on the right,
which is from the phase three trial, was published.
You can see qualitatively the conclusions are similar between these
two, and I would say this is a good example of how the two data sources can be
used in complementary ways. Real-world data gave us an answer more
quickly that could fill an evidentiary gap while the randomized
control trial was ongoing. But because of the higher risk of
bias and the limitations of data quality in real-world data,
we still need the randomized trial results to ultimately confirm
and augment what we'd found in real-world data.
So what are these data quality limitations that I'm alluding to?
There are three different types of discrepancies that
arise between real-world data and randomized controlled trials that could
potentially introduce bias into our analyses.
And on this slide, I've grouped them into three components, differences in the
patients, differences in the care environment, and differences in the
data quality.
Differences in the patient population between patients participating in a trial
and patients captured in a real-world data source, I would describe as
representing a source of selection bias.
So the patients who either have had the opportunity or have chosen to participate
in a trial are not necessarily the same as patients in the
broader patient population being treated in the real world.
Additionally, typically, oncology clinical trials have a lengthy list of
eligibility criteria, and many of those eligibility criteria are
measured inconsistently or incompletely in real-world data sources.
So although we'd like to look at the same patient population meeting the same
eligibility criteria in the real world and in a randomized trial, we're
often unable to do so because of the limitations of the data source.
The supportive care environment in the real world also potentially
differs from that in the trial environment, and that could represent
aspects of treatment delivery or supportive care as well as
monitoring. So if monitoring of patients, if follow-up
is different between the trial environment and real-world environment,
then potentially outcome ascertainment is also going to look different between the
two data sources, and this could also lead to the appearance of
treatment heterogeneity between the two data sources.
And then finally, the data themselves.
If you think of data sources like electronic health records or administrative
claims data, the data themselves are much more
heterogeneous, are inconsistently collected, have
unprespecified methods for outcome ascertainment, are
missing many of the data elements that we're interested in, and in many cases,
we're going to be deriving the data elements that we want to use from structured
fields such as ICD codes or procedure codes, which
have heterogeneous coding conventions across clinical
systems, across clinicians. And those differences in things like
coding conventions could create spurious appearance of differences
between treatments in the trial environment versus the
real-world environment.
So one opportunity for incorporating data from the real
world into a clinical trial is by augmenting the
control arm of a trial with patients from a real-world data
source who are receiving the same treatment.
There are two different ways that we could consider doing that.One is
via an externally controlled trial.
So in an externally controlled trial, we would have a single-arm
trial in which patients solely receive the experimental treatment,
and then we're going to compare those patients to those receiving a standard of
care treatment in the real world.
That approach has a high risk of bias because all of the differences between
real-world data sources and trials that I just described on the previous
slide
will erroneously or spuriously look like differences between
the experimental treatment and the standard of care.
In other words, all of those differences that are attributable to the data source
and the environment will be 100% confounded with the
comparison of the two treatment arms.
Another opportunity is the hybrid control trial design.
So in the hybrid control trial design, we'll take a randomized trial in which
patients are randomized to the experimental treatment as well as the standard of
care,
and then we're going to augment that internal control arm with an additional
external control arm drawn solely from real-world data.
So in this trial design, we have patients receiving the standard of care
treatment, both in the context of the trial and in the real world.
That allows us to distinguish between differences between the two treatments
and differences between the care environments and the data quality.
So the hybrid control trial design, while also potentially suffering from
bias by introducing differences between real-world data and
randomized trial data,
is able to accommodate those differences by leveraging information
comparing those two treatment arms, the control-treated patients in the
trial and the control-treated patients in the real world.
The reason that we might be interested in conducting a hybrid control trial despite
the potential limitations and the potential introduction of bias, is that
it may decrease the overall size of the randomized trial
portion of the study, so we may be able to complete the trial more
quickly and more cheaply.
We could potentially also accelerate enrollment because it allows us to vary the
randomization ratio towards the experimental arm.
So rather than randomizing patients one to one, we could randomize a higher
proportion of patients into the experimental arm, which may be more appealing both
to patients and clinicians and may accelerate enrollment into the
trial. However, all of the differences between the data sources
and the patient populations that I mentioned are potentially going to bias our
comparisons and need to be carefully addressed via our analysis and
design.
So at a high level, there are four different ways that we could think about
analyzing a hybrid control trial.
In the slides that I have coming up next, I'm illustrating
the randomized trial portion of the study by the two
circles on the right,
the internal control arm and the intervention arm.
So patients are randomized to those two arms, and they have the intervention arm
larger to represent that we're able to randomize more patients into the
intervention arm. The color of the patients inside the circles
represents the distribution of patient characteristics, and since the patients in
the randomized trial were randomly assigned to the control arm or the
intervention arm, the distribution of the colors of the figures in those two
circles should be the same.
In contrast, the real-world data control arm in green on the left
represents additional patients that we're going to use to augment the control arm
who come from the real world. And consequently, the distribution of patient
characteristics in that arm is not necessarily the same.
So to be very conservative, we could analyze only the patients from the randomized
portion of the trial, which we believe would control bias but would
be inefficient.
Conversely, we could fully incorporate information from the real-world control
arm, which I'm going to refer to as full pooling.
And under full pooling, we've now potentially introduced bias into our
study due to incorporating these patients who have different characteristics into
our control arm, but it's maximally efficient in that it
maximally uses the available information.
To try to account for that potential bias, there are a number of approaches that
are collectively referred to as static or dynamic borrowing.
And in these approaches, we're going to up or down-weight the information from that
real-world data control arm according to the similarity between the
real-world patients and the trial patients.
So in this example, the real-world patients are somewhat different from the trial
patients, and so that entire circle has been down-weighted to reflect
the fact that the evidence coming from that information is not quite
comparable to the trial information.
And then finally, we could take a propensity score-based weighting approach in
which rather than up or down-weighting the entire real-world data data
source, we're going to up or down-weight individual patients within
the real-world data control arm proportional to their similarity
to patients inside the trial. So patients in the real-world data control
arm who have characteristics that are underrepresented relative
to what that patient subgroup looks like in the trial would be
up-weighted. Those who are overrepresented would be down-weighted.
I'm going to show you the relative performance of these different approaches in a
few simulation studies in which I'm going to vary the strength of the true
treatment effect. I'm going to show you results for a randomization
ratio of two to one, and then I'm going to vary the strength of confounding,
by which I mean the systematic difference between patients in the real
world and patients in the trial, between what I'm going to refer to as mild
confounding and strong confounding.
And I'll show you results for bias, type one error, and power.
So these are results as we vary the hazard ratio, the true treatment effect
across the x-axis from about 0.5 up to one
for each of the methods that I've discussed.
So in green, I have bias results for the trial.
We expect that the trial is unbiased, it's protected by randomization, and you see
that's what this slide illustrates.If we fully pull
in all of the information from the real-world data, that's
represented by the red line, and it has very substantial bias.
We can reduce that bias by using a static borrowing approach,
which downweights the evidence from the real-world data source.
But you can see all of the blue lines here also demonstrate
significant bias due to that systematic confounding, that systematic difference
between real-world and trial patients.
And then finally, if we take a propensity score-based approach, we're able to
eliminate that bias. But an important caveat here is,
although the propensity score is appropriately adjusting for systematic
differences, it relies on the assumption that we have access to all of the
covariates, all of the confounders that we need to adjust for in order
to be able to explain those differences.
Type one error follows very similarly to what you would expect based on those bias
results. The trial controls type one error because of the systematic
bias in full pooling and all of the static borrowing approaches.
They have enormously inflated type one error in this example, and the
propensity score weighting approach is able to return type one
error to approximately the nominal level.
And then finally, if we look at power, you can see that we apparently get a
power boost from full pooling or the static borrowing approaches.
But we know that those approaches lead to inflated type one error.
So we wouldn't want to trust these power results essentially because we know that
this increase in power is due to the bias in those approaches.
The propensity score-based approach, which was approximately able to control type
one error, still gives us a power boost.
So we are getting some benefit from incorporating the real-world patients,
without inflating type one error or introducing bias.
I'll wrap up just by showing you what this looks like in a real-world example.
So in this study, I used data from a real trial
comparing two different treatments for prostate cancer, in which patients were
randomized to the experimental arm or the standard of care at a two to one
ratio.
I then created a pseudo real-world data arm in which I resampled
patients from the control arm of the trial, but I did it according to sampling
probabilities that systematically distorted the relationship
between patient covariates and whether or not a patient was seen in the
trial environment or the pseudo real-world data environment.
What I mean by that is shown here. So here I'm summarizing a few of the patient
characteristics for the patients in this trial.
You can see with the control arm and the intervention arm, which were randomized,
all of the patient characteristics are distributed similarly.
In the pseudo real-world data arm, because I have sampled the patients according
to ECOG performance status and according to PSA, I've
systematically distorted this distribution relative to the way that it
looks in the trial.
The implication is that if we compare survival in those three sources,
the pseudo EHR or pseudo real-world data arm has much poorer
survival compared to either of the two arms in the trial.
So you can imagine if I just naively pool the yellow patients in with the blue
patients, there's going to be a massively inflated
apparent treatment effect. Patients treated with the standard of care are going to
look like they do much more poorly than patients receiving the experimental
treatment in the context of the trial.
Here are point estimates and confidence intervals for each of the methods that I'm
describing, and I'm comparing them to the black vertical bar, which
is the point estimate from the trial, and then the gray bar around
it is the confidence interval from the trial.
Similar to the simulation results, you can see that full pooling and the static
borrowing approaches are enormously biased.
They give us an estimate very far away from the trial estimate.
Dynamic borrowing, which dynamically determines how much information we
want to incorporate from the real world, depending on similarity between the
patient populations, gets us back to something very close to the trial,
but also barely increases efficiency.
So the width of the confidence interval in the dynamic borrowing setting is
almost exactly the same as the width of the trial-only estimate.
Both of the propensity score-based approaches get us closer to
the trial-only estimate, and in particular, the propensity score-based weighting,
which is more flexible than a stratification approach, gets us very close to the
trial and has reduced
the width of the confidence interval by quite a bit.
So in conclusion, there are a lot of opportunities for using
real-world data to address some of the limitations of clinical trials,
including their speed, their cost, and their limited
generalizability. But there are many methodological challenges that we have to
think about carefully, particularly related to data quality.
So we really need to reflect carefully on those three sources of discrepancy
between real-world data and trials that I mentioned earlier and think
about the approaches that we're going to use to address things like missing data,
measurement error, and differential outcome ascertainment.
There are also systematic differences between trial and real-world patient
populations and care environments that we have to be careful to use
methods that will allow us to disentangle differences between
those care environments and patient populations and differences in treatments
that we want to compare. I think there are a lot of opportunities
for addressing these challenges via methodological innovation.
I think that advances in AI, especially LLMs, do
hold the potential to unlock additional confounder information from the
EHR, which would allow us to use these real-world data more
effectively. But we have to do so in a way that preserves
transparency and preserves research rigor, so we don't degrade the quality of
the evidence as we bring in additional real-world data.
Thank you.
Thanks, Rebecca. Great start.
And for those who came in
a little bit late, we are going to give all three talks
and then have a panel discussion at the
end to address
topics that come up.
The next speaker is Dr. Neil Meropol,
who is Senior Advisor to Flatiron Health,
and he is the Principal Investigator Elect of the
ASCO TAPER study.
Neil.
Thanks, Peter.
Okay, well, I'm going to provide
a complementary
perspective on the use of real-world data in clinical trial design and
execution, coming from the perspective of
an oncologist who's been a clinical investigator and
a health outcomes researcher working with real-world data, in
particular,
data derived from electronic health records.
So my talk is going to be divided into
two broad sections. The first, I'm going to talk about how we go
about curating, extracting research-ready data
from electronic health records, and then move on from there to
how that curation approach can be
applied to supporting clinical trials.
To amplify on what Rebecca
discussed previously, there are a variety of forms
of real-world data, data relating to patient health
status, routinely collected
in a variety of ways. And my focus is going to be on electronic health
records, but for completeness, I'm highlighting some of the other
sources here.
Why are people interested in EHRs as a
data resource for clinical research?
Rich source of patient-level data.
It integrates multiple data sources, radiology,
genomics, laboratory, clinical, pathologic.
The documentation happens in real time, so you can actually get a
very current picture of a patient
journey through the electronic health record.
The information's digitized, so it's ready to be curated,
to be analyzed in its native form.
Because it's part of the routine clinical care
workflow, EHR data as a real-world data source
is really great for understanding how care is delivered.
And finally, in terms of representativeness, it's well known
that the patients who take part in traditional clinical trials tend
to not be representative of the overall patient population.
Real-world data, on the other hand, has the potential to be fully
representative.
So when I think about the types of data that could be
obtained in the electronic health record, and this relates to how we
curate those data, there are three broad types of data.
One are the structured data that is entered as numbers,
drop-down fields, laboratory values, and so forth.
There's unstructured EHR data that
finds its way in through physician narratives
and reports of radiology and so forth.
And then there are external data sources,
like
genomic data that are performed in a
third-party laboratory. They might be sent in as
PDFs and integrated into the EHR.
There are claims data that are not typically part of the EHR.
There's mortality data from obituaries that are used to
supplement mortality variables when EHRs are used for
research that come from external sources.
And through tokenization and other methods, these can be linked with
EHR data.
Now, in terms of the unstructured EHR data, this is the biggest nut to crack,
because it requires interpretation of data
that are not research-ready.
And there are three broad categories, and this is a very
rapidly evolving field. There are three ways that these data are
typically curated today. One, shown on the bottom, is human
abstraction. This has been historically the gold standard.
A person reading a chart and turning a
sentence into a data element ready for analysis.
There are
machine learning approaches that are applied to
basically natural language process
reading of charts, and the machine learning
algorithms are trained and
tested against
a gold standard data set that has been human
curated. And then more recently, the application of large language
models. So being able to prompt the machine with
routine conversational language to give instructions
for what the machine should do in terms of reading the chart and pulling out
information, again, requiring validation of the approach.
So how do we
assess the quality of real-world data obtained from EHRs?
This is absolutely critical for minimizing bias as
much as you can related to the data that are
obtained. So there's questions of reliability.
Is that data element actually what was
documented in the chart? Do two methods of
interpretation or two interpreters over time come up with the
same data point?For that
particular parameter.
How relevant is the data in the EHR to the research
question? You'll hear a lot about fitness for purpose, and that's absolutely
critical in understanding whether a real-world data source is
appropriate to be integrated with clinical trial data.
There's issues of completeness and missingness.
Sometimes data are simply not documented.
Sometimes they are documented, but it's
incomplete documentation.
How representative is the patient population in the real-world data
source? And finally, provenance is really important,
especially as you get into regulatory use cases where
the FDA would like to have the ability to trace every data
element that is submitted back to its source document.
And not all real-world data sources have complete provenance, but this
is pretty important.
So a number of frameworks have been proposed for how to go about
assessing the quality of real-world data, and in
particular, real-world data that is obtained by
machines, whether it's large language models,
whether it is machine learning approaches.
And here's one approach here
that looks at a variety of different
metrics for assessing data quality.
One being data quality at the variable level.
One being verification checks, a reality check of
whether the cohort-level variable makes
sense. Are there cases where a
diagnosis date
is coming after the date of metastasis?
That doesn't make intuitive sense, and that's a type of
reference check that could be used to assess the quality of the
curation method. And then finally, there's replication and benchmarking
analyses. I'll show an example of that where you take the
overall analysis of the curated
data
and do a reality check on its
performance against some benchmark, perhaps the control
arm of a randomized clinical trial.
Or
both the experimental and control arm of a randomized clinical trial
if that experimental drug is now
licensed for routine use.
So these different types of metrics for
assessing quality
are operationalized by comparing to the gold standard,
by comparing to a human abstractor,
or comparing two abstractors' work to each other and
coming up with scores for data quality.
And different parameters might require different levels
of performance to be fit for use for a particular use
case, a particular context. So here's one example that's been
published. This is looking at the variable of real-world
progression-free survival. So progression of disease based
on clinician documentation in the electronic health record,
comparing human abstraction of the date of progression to
an LLM.
Looking at-- this is Flatiron data across a number of
different diseases,
basically showing that the LLM-extracted data, it looks like single
curves on each of these plots, but they're actually two curves that are
superimposed on each other,
showing that the performance of the LLM model for this particular
variable at the cohort level has a
high level of reliability.
So taking a step back now, you're able to curate
electronic health record data, both the structured data through
harmonization to a data model, the unstructured data through a
variety of methods.
What can those data be used for? Well, here's an example
of a clinical question.
Can checkpoint inhibitor therapy be discontinued after a
prolonged period of response in patients with non-small cell lung cancer?
The result being that the curves of fixed duration and
indefinite treatment in real-world cohorts
are superimposable.
So a clinically relevant question being asked of an
EHR-derived real-world data set.
And those data were largely human
abstracted. What about moving to
LLM-extracted EHR data?
So in this experiment, these are patients with bladder cancer who
technically were not eligible to receive cisplatinum because of poor renal
function, but underwent adjuvant therapy or neoadjuvant
therapy with cisplatinum nevertheless in the real
world.
And this
study showed that, in fact, in real-world practice,
many patients who are technically not eligible to receive
cisplatinum do receive cisplatinum.
And when they do, those patients that do actually have better
outcomes than patients who did not receive cisplatinum.
Suggesting that there might be characteristics that ought to be
identifiable
for patients that on paper shouldn't receive a therapy but
might benefit from that therapy and, in fact, should receive it
in variance to what historically has
been considered as guideline approach.
Now moving on to another way of
extracting variables, in this case, using machine learning
algorithms. I'm going to show a series of three slides
in a single experiment looking at patients with
early-stage non-small cell lung cancerAnd asking
questions around the use of neoadjuvant therapy
and adjuvant therapy in the face of published
data suggesting that there are benefits in terms of patient outcome
from this approach.
So what this first slide shows is simply a pattern of care
experiment,
suggesting that
many patients who should be receiving genomic
analysis of their tumors are not in the left panel.
And in the right panel, showing that the implementation
of neoadjuvant and adjuvant therapy, in this case
with immune oncology therapy,
has been increasing over the past several years, but is
still at low levels. So there's perhaps an
adoption issue.
Second of all, what about outcomes in the real world?
And this slide shows the analysis,
looking at distant
metastasis-free survival of the
patients who received neoadjuvant therapy and adjuvant therapy,
showing excellent outcomes in those patients.
And as a reality check, or a pressure test of the
data, those patients with earlier stage disease did better
than patients with later stage disease, as you would expect.
And then as a sensitivity analysis, the authors asked the
question,
among those patients who received neoadjuvant
therapy, was there additional benefit to giving adjuvant
therapy after surgery in addition to that neoadjuvant therapy?
And this analysis suggests that, in fact, there isn't evidence
that reinstituting the therapy in the
adjuvant setting benefits.
So those are just some examples of what you can do with
real-world data derived from EHRs and showing
some,
in tabular form, something that Rebecca presented
previously,
what she called clinical trial data and
observational data?
Real-world data.
Real-world data as the second category.
I'm calling retrospective data, think of that as the real-world data, and
prospective data, data you obtain in a clinical trial.
Highlighting in a simplified manner that retrospective
data,
off-the-shelf ability to use it, spinning up a clinical
trial, obviously, takes much longer, is much more
costly.
Real-world data, retrospective data, higher level of representativeness,
reflective of practice in routine practice,
larger sample sizes.
On the other hand, clinical trial data, prospective data,
give you much better precision of the cohorts, being able
to pre-specify inclusion and exclusion criteria,
list all the covariates you're interested in and make sure you collect them,
measure outcomes in pre-specified ways like RECIST
criteria for tumor measurements in solid tumors, and the
ability to audit query sites and minimize
missingness of data. So pros and cons.
So moving on now to how real-world data can
support clinical trials, there are a lot of ways.
One way is you could look at your site or across the
country at real-world data from electronic health records to
determine whether it's feasible to do a clinical trial in a
particular population and how long it might take based on
how many eligible patients there are per unit time.
It can help you design the study in terms of what the inclusion and
exclusion criteria ought to be. Select sites based on
what sites have particular patient populations.
Match patients to the study eligibility based
on EHR data
and which can be automated.
Primary data collection. Many of the data necessary for clinical
trials exist in the EHR and through
automation, can be directly transferred into an
electronic data capture system for a clinical trial,
saving the manual transcription that often takes place in clinical
trials.
Long-term follow-up from real-world data sources could
enable
finding out mortality or resource utilization following
the completion of a shorter clinical trial.
And then with regard to the potential for
external control arm construction,
could be used to both provide
context for a single-arm clinical trial
or a formal comparison as an external control arm.
And then finally, there's a lot coming out now, a lot of interest in
creating digital twins from EHR data to
simulate experiments, intervention
experiments,
using real-world data and help predict
outcomes that could help you then design clinical experiments.
So a couple of examples here. This is a study
we did using real-world data to
model the impact of loosening inclusion and exclusion
criteria across a number of different diseases.
And we found that by loosening criteria just a
modest amount, you could increase the eligible population size by
78%. The strongest impact
was among patients and patient groups that are commonly
not well represented in clinical trials.
In another study, we looked at
leveraging the ability to curate
dataIn a number of ways, in a
study in collaboration with J&J, who was the sponsor of
this study in patients with multiple myeloma receiving
daratumumab, to understand the
feasibility of patient ascertainment, direct
transfer of clinical trial data from the EHR to
EDCs, and then the centralized
abstraction of unstructured notes to reduce
site burden and increase efficiency.
The bottom line was that patients were rapidly accrued to this pilot
study.
30% of the patients were either Black or Hispanic,
suggesting that perhaps centralized patient
ascertainment and prompting to the sites
assisted with representativeness, and the level of
data missingness was very low.
Transfer time,
receipt of data in the EDC was rapid,
and resolution of queries was also very rapid using this
platform.
I'm now going to give another example now, moving on to
the external control arm use case.
This is hot off the press, and the presentation's
available online from the Friends of Cancer Research,
where a pre-competitive experiment
was supported by the Friends of Cancer Research to
bring together a variety of data
suppliers, if you will, of real-world data to construct
external control arms and explore the feasibility
of doing so and what the pitfalls might be.
The target population was the RESOLVE clinical
trial. That was a randomized study in metastatic
adenocarcinoma of the pancreas, patients receiving gemcitabine and
nab-paclitaxel, and the external data cohorts were
constructed and compared to the control arm of the
RESOLVE study. The statistical analysis plan,
matching
algorithms were all determined a priori.
There was adjustment for
confounding in all of the datasets
with propensity scoring, and then
survival curves were generated for each
of the datasets that participated.
I'm going to run through a series of slides extremely quickly in the interest of
time and get to the punchline, but
suffice it to say that different data sources, shown here as
A through H, had different levels of attrition when going through the
inclusion and exclusion criteria for different variables.
Some data sources have certain variables available, others did not,
both laboratory and clinical variables.
After balancing, most of the data sources did a pretty darn good
job balancing the populations for analysis through
statistical means,
and the characteristics
post-balancing were generally good,
and you can see here in the boxes, there were some
that were less aligned, if you will, with
the RESOLVE trial. The question being for
further analysis is how much do the variables
that could not be matched well contribute to the outcomes of
the experiment? And here's the punchline.
Six datasets were able to be matched and
curves generated.
For the most part, the curves performed very well when
compared to the control arm of the RESOLVE trial,
and further analyses are being undertaken to
understand which variables might have contributed the
most
to the situations where the curves did not align
as well.
So, to sum up,
prospective clinical trials, randomized clinical trials are
the gold standard.
However, access to real-world data,
curation methodologies, and
sophisticated methods for analyzing those data have
matured to the point where real-world evidence has really come of age
and can support clinical trials in a variety of ways.
It's key to pay attention to data reliability, relevance,
the source of the data, and its provenance when assessing
fitness for purpose.
And real-world data overall, because all patients
participate in the generation of real-world data
if EHRs are used for their care,
allows broader participation in clinical research,
ensuring representative patient populations and results
that are generalizable. Thank you.
Thanks, Neil. A great summary
of the EHR.
Let me see how we
get to the next...
How do we get out of this? Thank you.
I think it might be this one.
Let's
see.Okay.
Thank you.
So I'm Peter O'Dwyer. I am
a medical oncologist at the University of Pennsylvania,
co-chair of the ECOG-ACRIN
Research Group, cancer research group.
And in this final talk,
we'll address the implementation of
a real world data study
as part of an
FDA collaboration.
And the idea here is that this study was performed
in the cooperative group.
So I'll address two issues here. One is
the real world data
from prospective studies, the rationale, and the
implementation. I'll just remind you of the
slide that Neil just showed
of prospective and retrospective.
This prospective analysis fits kind of in the middle
between the retrospective, which is the EHR,
and the clinical trial, which is ultimately the prospective.
This one,
as a prospective study, is conducted at the same time
as the clinical trial, and you'll see the rationale for that.
And secondly, talk about changes to the use
of the EHR
that
may be useful in
terms of developing high-quality data.
Now, Dr. Hubbard already showed the differences between the
phase III trial and the real world,
or phase IV, often referred to as phase IV studies.
The real world includes all patients who may benefit
from the treatment, not just those who can bench press 200 pounds.
Who are those patients? They're patients with variable performance
statuses. They have diversity. They live in different
environments.
They have comorbidities, and different economic
circumstances, all of which have been shown to
determine outcome of cancer treatments.
In the real world, as has been emphasized, missingness is a source of
bias, and that's something that we don't have in clinical
trials.
The interpretation of the real world data
has been shown and discussed,
but what's important to know is that only
3% to 7% of patients treated for cancer
are treated on clinical trials. So if you
want a picture of
the effect of these treatments in the whole population, you need to go
to the whole population.
The FDA
has been the prime mover of
analyzing
the effects of treatments that they approve
as new therapies for cancer in the real
world.
This started off with the 21st Century Cures Act in 2016,
and over the last decade, there have been, I think, seven
guidances of increasing specificity
from the FDA to help
define how these studies should be conducted.
And essentially, the studies in the real world, you could think of them
as registry trials.
That's essentially
what they are.
They have some characteristics that are slightly different, and we'll talk about
those, too. But the considerations are
underpinned by epidemiological design principles,
which we don't usually take into account because we don't have to.
We have all of the data in phase III trials.
The
FDA issued an RFA
directed to addressing gaps in knowledge that
limit the usefulness of real world data and real world evidence.
That was in 2023.
And it caused us in the cooperative
group to reappraise the role of the group
in therapeutic research.
Normally,
the studies in the group address themselves to phase II trials or phase
III trials,
often with registration intent. But that
further analysis, as shown in the red box here, was thought
to be a valuable contribution that we could make
with institutions that span the country,
including cancer centers, community sites, large and small,
and
an important geographic distribution.
So our proposal was very simple,
and reducing the phase III trial to its
simplest design of a novel therapy
versus the standard therapy.
You know that if the trial is positive and
it's successful, that that novel therapy can
then be approved by the FDA for use
outside clinical trials. Post-approval, there may
be real world data studies, there may be phase IV trials, and
they can come up with results, but how do you
interpret those results? To what do you compare the
results? So our thought was that in
order to provide databases that would be
collected robustly,
that one should collect real world data on the control
arm while the phase III trial is
ongoing.We identified
a study in ECOG-ACRIN in non-small cell lung cancer,
EA5182, that
seemed to serve the purpose of this
type of design. The trial is a randomized study of
osimertinib versus osimertinib plus
bevacizumab in patients with non-small cell lung
cancer harboring a mutation
in the EGF receptor.
The trial had just begun at the time that
we started this effort, so we were able to design in
parallel PRECOG 1702
and to register patients treated with
osimertinib
or osimertinib plus chemotherapy outside the confines
of a clinical trial. Why two arms here?
Well, just because at the time that we were planning an
osimertinib study, the FLORA II data for
osimertinib plus chemotherapy were starting to emerge,
showing a potential benefit for patients
treated with the combination. So we thought it could be useful in
a real-world setting to accrue data on both
arms.
Now, if
these
types of workshop
should have a slide that is the main
how-to slide,
this is it for this presentation. The
data to be captured in a prospective real-world data
registry
need to be as carefully defined as
those in the phase III trial. And it goes back
to, as
both Neil and Rebecca mentioned, the idea
that the fatal flaw in interpreting
real-world data occurs if you have excessive
missingness of the data.
So the key variables for propensity scoring
are listed here. I won't go through all of them.
But we define those as the variables that would
count to estimate the quality of the
study. Completeness of these data was an
epidemiological priority.
The main goal of this study was feasibility because we
hadn't done this before.
Other endpoints included real-world endpoints
for treatment effectiveness, and these include real-world
progression-free survival, time to treatment
discontinuation, and overall survival.
And there were additional exploratory endpoints.
The study isn't complete, so I won't be discussing any of these today.
The trial status.
This study had a very slow start.
It was unfamiliar in the setting of
the research efforts in institutions
where the
staff are used to developing clinical
trials, registering patients on a clinical trial, and then determining
the treatment. This was totally different.
It was registering a patient who had just started
treatment and then following just the data.
As you'll see in a moment, actually, the treating physician had a
very minor role in the data set that
we were getting. The most important person was actually the clinical
research associate.
This
trial suddenly took off after about a year
of very slow accrual and is now accruing
at
about 25 patients per month, which is where we had
targeted the accrual from the beginning.
A
couple of months ago, we analyzed data from the first 80 patients, and we
were able to show that even before data
cleaning,
that the prospective model yields an expected data
quality over 85% capture of the key variables.
And let me just talk about two aspects of this.
One is engagement with the site CRAs, and the second,
the establishment of a network of institutions that are
interested in this type of work.
The CRA is the linchpin at each site, whether it's in a
community site or in a cancer center.
The barriers that we've identified
are shown here. I won't read through all of them.
And you can see that some solutions can be provided.
Some are
conjectural.
There's a decline in consent that we've noted among
elderly patients.
We don't understand that, but are continuing
to, as I show here, continuing to refine
the message. But the key interaction is
between the project manager in this study, staying in
regular contact with the CRA at the
institution.
And secondly, we now have a network for prospective
real-world data studies.
We generated this
design after two symposia at cooperative
group meetings. Input from the specialists is shown
here. Now we have active accrual from 40 institutions.
As in clinical trials, you need
an adequate number of sites.And this provides an
adequate number of sites for this particular trial.
We're continuing to expand the
participant list. There's participation
here from various types of centers
treating cancer patients and
also
good geographical diversity.
The studies we expected to be IRB exempt,
but they weren't for two reasons. One
was patient-reported outcomes, and the other was social determinants
of health. We have work to do with IRBs
to determine how we can make a
very light regulatory
barrier to getting these studies activated.
The current regulations contribute to both expense
and delays in getting the studies up and running.
And I do have to say that acceptance of trials like
this did require a degree of culture change.
It's different from clinical trials activities
that are done normally.
What challenges and opportunities are there?
Well, the
EHR is still
going to wind up as probably the most valuable
source of information.
Neil has outlined the obstacles in curation.
But even for these trials, the prospective trials, target
populations are underrepresented.
We need tech solutions that are broadly applicable,
and institutional fit with the characteristics
shown here are going to be an important component of the future.
So let me switch then to consider
the EHR from a different perspective in
relation to prospective clinical trials of this nature.
The weaknesses of the EHR are twofold.
One is how you interrogate it, but the second
is how the EHR is built, what
data are recorded in the EHR by the
treating physician and others.
So,
the current status,
I think
this has really been dealt with
adequately by
Neil.
But I think just to go to the end of this, that the surrogate
endpoints are limited by lack of
documentation and definition of progression events, and these come
from multiple studies by Friends of Cancer Research before the
current one. So structured approaches and
AI have the potential to increase
reproducibility, particularly.
Two approaches to data quality from the EHR have
recently been published. One from the
Duke-Margolis Institute, which has had a huge role in
developing
approaches to real-world data curation and real-world evidence
generation.
Here, the
FDA's criteria for the life cycle of
EHR data, which is data accrual, curation, and
transformation to allow analysis,
were discussed, and the
complexity
of EHR-derived data curation is addressed.
The recommendations from Duke Margolis are to
implement real-world data best practices and develop
tools to address pertinent regulatory concerns for
curation. And again, the proposal
to involve AI in
these models is front and center.
And almost at the same time, the European Medicines
Association developed a data
quality framework, as shown here.
And again, the recommendation was to
implement best practices
in
developing regulatory quality real-world data.
The table
shows some of the domains that are important
in the quality assessment. You see in the top
line,
reliability, extensiveness, coherence,
timeliness, and relevance are the key elements
that
determine the quality of data and determine their value.
At the University of Pennsylvania, we have collaborated
both with ECOG-ACRIN and others to
develop complementary approaches.
One, the top one here, Chart Hero,
is a program, a large language model, that
interrogates the
medical record for various purposes.
The second is called OncAssessment,
and this was developed to try and put
structure on the medical record of
patients who are being taken care of routinely.
Both are based on the Epic
electronic health record.
This shows Chart Hero, and the example I'm giving you is
not
from oncology. This is a patient who
shows up with a new atrial fibrillation.
And the question is: What is the CHADS
vascular score?Because that determines how these new
patients are
treated.
And this score would ordinarily take
the treating physician, or better, a fellow, going
through a voluminous patient's chart to extract the data.
The large language model can extract that data right away,
provide the score, and the patient's treatment can go forward.
The oncology assessment tool
is an Epic-based smart form.
It captures the clinical oncology data in structured format
from the perspective of the treating physician.
It's really easy to use.
This is what it looks like. In the gray at the top of
the slide,
these are data that are entered at the first
time you use the form. The first time you see the patient, you
record what the
cancer
characteristics are and what
metastatic
sites are present.
Below,
in the white panels, are a
point-and-click set of conditions for the
patient who is seeing you in the clinic.
You estimate the characteristics of the patients.
You specify
what changes in management are occurring and why.
And those are the two questions that are most commonly
missing in the EHR. So this has the
potential to solve that problem if it's
widely adopted.
So, next steps will be to
continue to perform these prospective
real-world data analyses.
We have two or three additional studies in the hopper.
We want to expand the network of institutions.
We think it's valuable to avail of the resources of a cooperative
group to develop real-world evidence and
benchmark these data against other approaches
of developing real-world data.
So in conclusion,
the real-world data from
deliberate prospective studies on the control arms of Phase
III trials likely score high on
reliability, coherence, relevance, and
timeliness.
We do need consultation with IRBs to address regulatory
issues with social determinants of health and
patient-reported outcomes.
And the EHR is the richest source of real-world
data. Increasing focus on structure,
tools, data quality
is going to be important and is needed for
extensiveness and generalizability.
We ask the question: Is this the model for real-world evidence that meets
regulatory standards? That on one side you have Phase
III clinical trials,
on the other, on the extreme right, you have real-world data from the
electronic health record.
But in the middle, you have a useful benchmarking approach,
which involves real-world data from prospectively
designed studies.
With that, let me conclude.
Credit my colleagues who've been instrumental in developing these approaches
and implementing this trial,
and the advice and insight
of Jeff Allen from Friends of Cancer Research and Dr.
Meropol, who's sitting right here.
So, thank you for your attention.
So now we have
about 20 minutes for
a Q&A session and a panel discussion.
So questions will come up, I think,
using this QR code. If you
put them into the system, the questions will come up.
If there are questions
in the room, please, we have one taker here at the
right side of the microphone. Go ahead.
All right. Nasir Habibi. Hi, Peter.
Who is the sponsor usually of the real-world evidence?
The sponsor of what?
Who's what?
Who's the sponsor usually?
Of which?
Who sponsor the real-world evidence studies?
Oh, in general?
In ge-
In general, yeah.
Do you want to answer that?
So there are a variety of
different types of sponsors.
One set of sponsors is the biopharmaceutical
industry,
biotech and pharma,
who use real-world data to make drug
development decisions, to understand drug use in the post-marketing
setting,
and a variety of other use cases.
If I was to think of the dominant
support for
real-world data
curation, it would be biopharma.
But at the same time, individual institutions, as you heard from
Peter,
support some real-world data studies, the
NCI,
through the cooperative groups, the FDA.
Heard a couple of examples
today. So there is
broad support both from public and
private entities for what is
frankly a super expensive enterprise to generate these
data.
So I have a question, two questions actually for Dr. Hubbard.
First, enjoyed your talk tremendously.
The first question is when one designs
a platform design
trial and is going to roll
experimental arms in and out, we always have that trouble of drift,
right? Patients may do better on the control arm over time
as care improves. How does one account for
that with real-world data? And my second question is, since you
are using controls that get the
standard of care in the community, can you not
conversely take the patients who have been treated with
your experimental arm off-label or in the earlier studies, the
phase one, phase two studies, to enhance the experimental
side?
Yeah. Thanks for those questions.
I think they both relate to how
we've historically thought about designing these types of studies, which
is not in terms of real-world data, but in terms of historical data.
So, that discussion, that idea of incorporating,
say, control data from an earlier trial where what's now the standard of
care was experimental treatment, I think that concept has been around for 50
years.
But exactly as your first question hit on, one of the concerns there is about the
temporal differences between patients in the current environment and in the past.
So I do think with real-world data,
one of the strengths is that we can potentially have better temporal alignment
of the patients coming from a real-world control arm with patients in the
randomized trial.
I think there are opportunities like Peter was discussing, where you're actually
doing prospective collection of patient data
from the EHR at the same time that the trial is ongoing to try to address that.
More broadly, I would say
that temporal drift, temporal misalignment between the patients kind of rolls
up to become yet another source of potential confounding between
the two arms.
And so to the extent that you're willing to make some parametric
assumptions about changes in time, changes in patient outcomes
over time, you could try to model it away.
You could try to incorporate as a confounder, as long as there's some
overlap.
But that, of course, is risky because it relies on assumptions.
I would say to your second question, which is I think a very exciting idea,
most of the time,
I'm assuming that while there's the opportunity to see patients receiving the
standard of care treatment in the real world, probably the experimental treatment
is not yet available, and so you're not going to see patients, at least not in
large numbers, receiving that in routine care.
But there's certainly possibilities, there's opportunities where that might not be
the case, either because of off-label use,
or other situations where the experimental treatment has already come
into use in routine care. And so I think
there's not really methodological work addressing that, the idea of
augmenting both arms of the trial with real-world data.
But that would actually be a very strong design because that gives you yet another
opportunity to try to disentangle differences between the two treatment arms
and the real-world versus
trial environment. So I actually think that's quite cool,
and there's a huge amount of methodological work in the statistical
literature on different analytic approaches for the hybrid trial
design. That kind of double hybrid design isn't something that people have really
been working on, but I think that's a cool opportunity.
Well, I hope you take it forward. You don't need to give me any credit, but...
And Dr. O'Dwyer, a quick question for you.
So one of the things that during my 40 years in
practice
was always touted was patients on clinical trials, even on the
control arm,
did better than the patients in the community, and there are
lots of explanations. One of them was that they're just getting more
oversight in their care. The design that you proposed
would allow you to actually answer that question.
So if you took that central group, the ones that are on the
prospective real-world trial,
and compared them to the sort of more classical real world,
you'd actually be able to answer that question, if enrollment does
change outcome even though it's real world.
Yes. I think we need to analyze that when
we get more data on this study. I think it's a very interesting
possibility that just being
watched
increases the attention.
The
patients who are treated on these prospective studies, though,
there is no contact with the treating physician.
The study is not telling the treating physician what to do, what
doses to give.
Right.
No-
But they know the patient's on a study.
Yes.
Right. And that-
They know. And there is one point of contact, which is
when the patient
stops the treatment, the CRA is
tasked with finding out from the physician why.
Did they stop because there was a scan that showed
progression? Was it because toxicity?
Other reasons?
So that we can try and get more granular with what's going on with the
patients.
Right. Thank you.
Thanks for the suggestion.
So it seems to me that historically, the closest thing that we had to
real-world data potentially was cancer registry data.
Yeah.
It had the problems of sampling and that sort of thing,
and the problem that historically it was all hospital-based and originating from
surgery, but the
structure was there in place, had all exactly these same
problems.
And I was wondering how cancer registries are
maybe being used in this or being expanded to take advantage, particularly of
capturing outpatient data, because having worked
in a large community cancer center for over 25 years, published 20 papers
based on registry data,
and when you go into the data, you start using the data, you find all the
problems with the data. That's when you realize it's there.
But it seems like the same issue, but it seems the structure at least was there to
potentially take advantage of that in this effort.
Yeah, I think it is. And
we
had lots of discussions with the people running the SEER
database
in the development of the design of these
studies. The SEER database is a tremendous
resource. It has some limitations, as you
outlined.
But just like the EHR, it overcomes those
limitations with numbers, and numbers are really key here.
So yes,
we are looking forward to integrating SEER
data into studies like this. Neil,
you've also had some experience.
Yeah.
I think it's a great point about registry data.
Registries are a great source of real-world
data.
It
really gets to this question of fitness for purpose again.
I realize I keep harping on this concept, but
the beauty of the registry is that you've established an a
priori data model, and the data are entered
into it.
But in terms of whether the use case,
whether it's fit for to ask a particular research question,
requires that that
data model that you set up 20 years ago or 100 years ago
is relevant to the question you're asking
today. But there actually are a few
examples of real-world data from registries
that have been used for FDA approval
recently.
And so,
it can be really valuable data.
Yes.
I have a question for Dr. Hubbard. I wanted to ask if, for
instance, we choose to
do an analysis on a real-world dataset, and we
decide the critical variables for a propensity score analysis.
But then, for example, we will find out that
for one specific variable, we have
a big number of missing data, like, I think
for instance, ECOG PS, we found out that 20% of patients
have missing data. Should we exclude those patients, or
are there some statistical analysis that we can use
to still consider these patients somehow in the trial?
Thank you.
So that's a really common problem.
Working with these data, missingness, I think as all of us have emphasized, is
really common.
And so I would say, in general, excluding patients with missingness is generally
not the best approach,
because it degrades the efficiency of your analysis and potentially introduces
selection bias. So there's actually a line of work that I think
is--
It seems like a really simple question, but it's very interesting, which is a
better approach would be to impute the missing data using multiple imputation.
But when you're combining a propensity score-based analysis with a multiple
imputation, the question comes up, should you impute the data and
then compute the propensity score from that imputed data,
meaning you'll have a different propensity score for each person every time you
repeat that process? Or should you compute the
propensity score for everyone who has complete data and then impute the propensity
score for the people who have missing information?
And
the short answer is the first approach is the better approach.
But depending on your specific use case, how much missing data there is,
how large your sample size is, and therefore how expensive
computationally doing the imputation is, you might have slightly
different considerations. But in general, I would advocate an approach that
allows you to keep all of the patients or as many as possible in the analysis
rather than dropping those with missing data, which can introduce bias.
And is there a
benchmark over which we can't impute because there are too
many missing data or?
So there's kind of a rule of thumb that
says that how you should determine how many
imputations you should do isn't based on the proportion of patients who
have missing data, but the fraction of missing information.
And I think this is a super interesting idea because it basically says you could
have missing data for 95% of patients, but if you have another
variable that contains almost the exact same information that's not missing,
then you're really not missing any information, you're just missing observations.
So I would use a criterion like that, fraction of missing information,
to try to determine whether or not it's reasonable to undertake an imputation,
as opposed to the proportion is missing, which often can look quite scary.
But for instance, in EHR, where performance status is
often missing, but you might have information on comorbidities or other
information that kind of relates to the same quantities, you may actually
be able to recover more information than you think.
Okay. Thank you.
Can I take advantage of Dr. Hubbard's presence on the panel as
well? So when I'm faced with missing data,
I'm always asking myself, is this missing at
random or is there some systematic reason why it's missing?
Like academic
clinicians document differently than clinicians
in community practices for particular variables.
Believe it or not,
academics are much worse at documenting stage
than community oncologistsAnd
why? I don't know, but it's a thing
that we've observed.
There's probably something systematic there.
Mm-hmm.
So
how do you think about those different reasons for missing this and how
that bears on how you adjust for it?
So in the missing data literature, and this is getting kind of methods
nerdy, but in the missing data literature, there are three general
missing data mechanisms: missing completely at random, missing at random, and
missing not at random. And so missing completely at random leads
to
no bias, pretty much under any analysis you might propose.
And that's when there's absolutely nothing systematic about the missingness.
It's completely random. It's like somebody just lost those records, and it's
nothing to do with anything else.
Missing at random is systematic missingness that's predictable based on the
data. So in some of the cases that you're talking about, like
clinicians in academic settings are less likely to record stage, that's a
systematic missingness, but it's a predictable systematic missingness because it's
missingness that's due to academic versus community site.
So if you have that kind of predictable missingness, that's actually not a big
concern. Imputation can handle that kind of setting.
So missing not at random is the really problematic one, where the value
of the variable itself is what determines whether or not it's likely to be missing.
I've seen methods in the literature, especially in the machine learning
literature, where people are claiming to have come up with fancy imputation
methods using deep learning that they claim can deal with missing at random.
If you see anything like that, don't believe it. It's a lie.
Nothing can save you if you have missing not at random missingness.
What it really comes down to is, is your data set rich enough
that you can leverage information from other variables to help you
predict the missing data?
So in cases where I think that we understand the missing
mechanism, I understand why it's missing, and we can potentially predict the
missing variable based on other information, then I don't get too worried.
It's the settings where... So to give an example, I was doing an analysis
using Flatiron data, and there was a lot of missingness in ECOG
performance status, which was an important confounder in our analysis.
And one of the clinicians working on the study said, "I'm concerned that the data
are missing not at random because I think the physician was possibly less likely to
record the score if it was a higher score." And I said, "Oh,
no. That's really a big problem because that's a systematic
missingness that we can't predict from other things in the data." So
I'm always on the lookout for missing at random data, and really the only thing you
can do there is a sensitivity analysis.
And I think we should, as we work more on these real-world data studies and deal
with these kind of significant data quality limitations in the
data sources we're working with, I think we should have a standard protocol
for the sensitivity analyses that we're going to conduct because things like
missing not at random missingness can never be completely ruled out, and you can't
solve them with any kind of fancy analysis.
That's great. There's a question
on the virtual
hub here.
"How do you think AI can be
best utilized safely
to make the clinical trial process most efficient?"
I think Neil.
Well, how could it be used everywhere?
How could it be used safely?
Safely.
Work in progress. One of the
problems with
the implementation of AI tools in anything
having to do with clinical care is that it is
the highest stakes scenario. There's
really no room for error. So
what that's led to is this recognition that you got to have humans in the
loop,
and when you're using AI tools, there
needs to be gatekeeper oversight and
interpretation to make sure that what the AI is feeding
you
is accurate. But where I've seen it
have value is identifying patients for
clinical trials because that's not
recommending a treatment to a patient.
That's surfacing a patient who might be eligible for a
clinical trial. And that
could be super helpful because there are all sorts of implicit biases that
take place,
notwithstanding the fact that clinicians are
pressured for time and are trying to maintain their throughput of
patients and may not have time to be thinking about a clinical trial or taking
time to
undergo informed consent with a patient.
By
centralizing
the identification for clinical trials using
AI as an example, that could really, I think,
enhance the clinical trial process.
Another area that we've done some exploration of is could
AI be used to support the work of
clinical research associates who are trying to identify and
grade adverse events? Typically, a patient's on a
clinical trial, the CRA
is combing the clinical record for evidence that the patient had a
side effect and then querying the clinician about
grading and assigning attribution.
AI could potentially do that work of combing the
record for evidence of an adverse event and surfacing it
to the CRA with what is the
document that raised the suspicion.
So that's an example
in clinical trials that I think might be valuable.
And I'll just add directly onto that piece of, I think one of the
really excellent possibility is using LLMs to
augment research data
by combing through those records, improving the
completeness of the data elements that we have access to.
But I think a really important piece to go along with that is,
as Neil discussed in the validation study that he presented,
LLMs potentially make errors in ways that are very different from the kinds of
errors that humans make. They hallucinate things in a way that a human abstractor
wouldn't. So I think there's a lot of potential and also a need for
exactly that kind of validation study so that we understand
the improvements in the quality of the data, but also the potential
errors that are being introduced and what the structure of errors created by AI
look like.
Thanks. The red light is blinking, but you've been waiting to ask a
question.
Oh.
Thank you so much.
So if you have a brief question.
I would say that if we could start all over again, because the current
approach is trial and error.
If we were to start all fresh, no guess works,
right? We can actually get to the answer.
We can have LLMs that can give us the answer, give us a prediction.
What are the five steps frameworks that you see
us truly changing clinical trials in the future and just
going to version two or version five, whatever it is, but that
version completely gets rid of the guesswork.
What would be like the five steps you see towards getting there?
I think I can take that. I think that
what this session has shown is that there are
obstacles with getting to reality in the
data,
be it in the EHR or from other real
world data approaches, or any of the
claims data,
or indeed SEER data.
And if you were to design it
differently,
you would have all of the relevant data in structured forms
within the medical record. And from there, you could
start.
That would allow you to
develop designs for trials that would be hugely
more economical, that would
not give Dr. Hubbard a headache when she was looking at data
being brought in as external controls,
and it would be much more reliable.
So,
I'm not sure that there are five stages in this
because the reality is that we live in the real world.
But
any measures that we take towards refining
curation of the EHR and improving data quality that
way, or improving the EHR itself
through better documentation